thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I think that trans women should not be
part of the feminist movement I'm trans
so I was born female now I present as
male but I see a woman still I feel
feminine energy from you that's all
right so when you say you're a man then
it's like
I don't see that
emotional that means what do you define
as masculinity it can be subjective what
do you define I think masculinity is
whatever you wanted to be a woman's
whatever you wanted to be so then why do
you want to be a woman what are you even
subscribing to I hate the way that they
talk about this because it feels like a
Weasley way out of answering a question
that's really fundamental to the whole
discussion women have more privileges
today than men
I went back and forth on this one I just
have to ask
you guys in the comments can answer if
you had to choose
knowing that you supposed to believe
that women are more pleased would you
choose to be a woman
now of course do things to be true at
the time you could choose to want to be
a man and say women are more privileged
but me personally whatever Pleasures
women may have I just feel like men's
privileges suit me a lot better and I
prefer those than whatever women you
just like you just like being standing
up just say that I like not having
periods I don't care what nobody says if
I had to pay a monthly phone bill every
month in blood
flooded cramps I would hate that [__]
that's good no I get seasonal [__]
colds
monthly cramps with mood swings and
blood yeah nah bro
like we could have this discussion every
time I think about the viewer experience
I'm like I still choose a male
experience and even like one day I
mention certain things and hormones
pretty [__] up dealing with with the
kind of hormones that they deal with
yeah God damn that's me that's a hell of
a phone bill what's that overseas calls
and also like internationally speed like
maybe in a North American or Western
context like I can understand but on a
whole scale on a worldwide scale like
there's no way I'd ever want to be a
woman over a man yeah you start
traveling and that becomes more and more
apparent I mean you can't even travel to
a lot of places
you can't you can't travel alone
I will risk it so I don't know there's
just certain things that I think about
every time this conversation comes up
I'll be honest this is not me I just
wouldn't choose to be able I think
when privileges then men have but with
this new feminist movement that is
arising more of the third fourth wave we
are finding women are
placed and pedestalized above men in a
lot of ways there's affirmative action
hiring and scholarships where women
sometimes even regardless of academic
standing or achievement are prioritized
above men but men also have different
privileges that they get to access I
struggle to say more but I think I do
agree with the feminist movement now
there is more the feminist movement has
been all about women acting like they
don't have rights and acting like they
have it pretty hard in the modern day
world I can't think of a single thing
that I don't have that a guy has or that
they only I would say the one thing I
would say is the safety thing that's the
only thing that I would say is that
women are disadvantaged from by Nature
women are not as physically strong I
mean you're physically strong but as
physically I I would say this I actually
disagree with her on this point and I'm
surprised this is the one we disagree on
in terms of safety like men are
overwhelmingly the victims of violence
sure it's at the hand of other men but
it's like the idea that men have this
privilege of safety is like no we don't
I I don't buy that whatsoever we don't
have the privilege of safety but if
there's something to happen
I was about to say if there's something
that happens we're more likely to do
something about it
but no
but no the minute I said that I was like
yeah we're more likely to do something
about it because we're stronger but no
the aggression is going to come to our
way still come someone comes with a
knife if someone comes with a knife at
me someone comes with a gun [__]
it's just that
it's a feeling that they are there they
can't do anything about it right they
don't feel they don't feel as safe
because they're walking people are going
to think twice to fight me and to fight
a random girl but yeah we we are more
victim crimes yeah it's not that women
are safer I'll tell you better
definitely not safer is that we just as
Society care more about women's safety
because we consider them a quote-unquote
vulnerable population so same thing with
kids the amount of times people talk
about protecting kids you would think
there's an epidemic of like kids being
abducted every single thing but the
truth is the vast majority of violent
crimes happen against adult oriented
males so
we want to protect kids and it's a very
logical thing because they're a
vulnerable population in that same token
we view women kind of similarly
dude's getting murked every day listen
I'm going to talk a little bit more
about
um like the judicial system when it
comes to let's say domestic dispute if a
woman calls the police they
automatically show up arrest the man
this the Duluth model I think is how you
pronounce it and that's already in place
it's not necessarily like a right or
anything but it's certainly in all of
the police departments is that feminism
is all about equality why would you
automatically arrest a man when they
arrest him his name is in the newspaper
automatically the fact that a woman can
say Jane Doe and she doesn't have to put
her name out there what skin in the game
is there and there's so many instances
of that I know men personally who have
had domestic violence within their
relationship with children involved
unfortunately and the you know the woman
attacked the man in front of the child
and he's still I know two instances
personally and he's still fighting to
get the child back that's from the metoo
movement congratulations you guys got
that it kind of invalidates yo that [__]
that [__] went really quick by me yeah I
think she's trying to say that's the
result it's been around since before so
you know what it is it's just like
sometimes people have a problem with
like some they see in the world so they
just mention some buzzword like the woke
mind virus family courts have been
buying towards men before Harvey
Weinstein later her throwing that [__]
out yeah but I get what you're trying to
say is that ideology I think is what she
said I guess I think it's a mixed bag I
don't think the metoo movement was
inherently harmful it's the metoo
movement when you couple it with
something like believe all women that's
when it becomes uh and the victimization
of women who are really victims the
promptest do women have more privileges
we have privileges simply by virtue of
being women shout out to this girl
bringing it back to the conversation and
being balanced lady with a sleeve shout
outs to her you have privileges in
family court and we have privileges as
far as being believed and forgiven it's
a that's something that should be
acknowledged that's I think she made the
strongest case for the Privileges that
women have the idea of being believed or
inherently seen as some kind of Victor
worthy of of Praise or whatever the [__]
it is uh the family court bias
affirmative action these are all things
that are extremely valid that as a man
you just don't have access to but I'm
glad that she was like very concrete
very precise and she made a good case
the other ones it was a little bit iffy
moppy but it were that's like the thing
about being believed is very recent
women would not believe they were
dismissed when they were saying [__]
like that and that's why I believe her
movement happened because they were
dismissed they were in the past whenever
they were talking about the stories oh
well if you did that what did you do you
know what did you do to get in that
position or uh but the process women
have more privileges today so yeah did
that [__] exist in the past probably
yeah in some cases but today that's
definitely yeah yeah
gonna have the disagree a step forward
I appreciated the distinction of more
versus different privileges you can't
just use a broad brush and paint the
entire debate and say all right well
this is men have more than women that's
it like women that must inherently then
have no privileges that's that's not how
it works and that's where we start to
get into the idea of like
intersectionality where another woman
who had a different experience if it was
a trans woman if it was a woman of color
including trans women into feminism and
I think we definitely should oh based
woman whoa yes let's go
I'm not gonna lie there's something very
cringe about a male saying we should
include trans women in in women's rights
because you're assuming that everyone
adopts your ideology that trans women
are somehow in the same boat as females
and they're not they deal with their own
struggles their own experiences and
those are not akin to what women go
through traditionally so lumping all
that [__] together is when you really
start to hurt the trans woman because it
just makes women like yeah these people
don't go through what I go through why
you lumping in their rights is you you
know you're doing the women you're
lgbtqing them you throwing in other [__]
that ain't their experience into theirs
and then say they gotta adopt it that's
a no that's an L so shout out to this
woman because I agree and there's just
something really weird about male
feminist that always makes me
uncomfortable yeah yeah I think I think
it's just there's a there's a lot of
things there I believe that
there's also the fact that people
have been dressed in sheep cloaked
wolves I've been dressed in sheep
clothing so it's like it's very weird
where you have that thing happening
you're like okay but I what's in it for
you though because it's not it's not
about that equality thing so what what
what what's what's I've seen too many
people lowering people's guard with that
[__] being being saying that they are
saying that they are oh yeah I'm
pro-black and they're white and I'm like
are you hiding physicism I can't help it
okay you know what this is what this is
their blue hair
this is that I'm that special I'm your
friend yeah I'm I'm doing this for them
because sometimes especially when they
talk about this with other people who
don't share their political views
there's an air of condescension I'm like
bruh
you're not driving why are you talking
so loud I've had someone you know what
I'm saying like you're a passenger chill
out why are you trying to drive that
some white woman do some [__] like that
yeah try to lecture me about black stuff
I'm like yo if you don't get the you're
not telling me you lecturing me take a
back seat like when you trying to
explain it's funny because you're a man
and you're explaining to a woman things
about feminism and being a woman and
stuff like that and why they should or
should not and then shouldn't you be all
about mansplaining but that's what
you're doing right now that's what you
do you're trying to explain the the
experience to someone that's weird I
don't know I have a hard time with that
here's the thing he might not be wrong
but there's just something super strange
optically about a man lecturing a woman
about who should be included in women's
rights yeah and and she doesn't have
like some Fringe view she has a popular
view I think most women agree that trans
women should not be involved in women's
rights it's their own separate fight
yeah I think that trans women should not
be a part of the feminist movement
because a man just because they you know
wake up and feel like they can be a
woman one day could come in and then
suddenly know what it's like to have a
period or know what it's like to have a
child it's anything from men replacing
women in sports to men replacing women
on podcasts during women's month and
when we're talking about women's health
or you've even got biological men who
think they're women going to the White
House speaking on behalf of all women I
do have a question for you based on the
prompt though because you've lived in
both experiences at least socially I'm
curious when you transition to male and
people started perceiving you as male
like most people did today what
privilege has changed for you or what
did you see enter your life that you
didn't have before yeah and that's
that's sort of where a lot of my my
beliefs in feminism do lie is because
being out into the world as a gay woman
was the way I was seen men treated me
definitely not nearly as well as they
did I was bullied in school I had people
call me slurs and it seemed like it was
because I was threatening to like the
male structure that we were in where
it's like male and female because I was
a female who liked females I was somehow
infringing on that and so they didn't
like me things change naturally when you
socially transition and are perceived by
the world in a different way when I
transitioned from being perceived as
female to the world to just pretty much
passing or blending full-time as male
was that I got a lot more respect from
other other men people listened to me
and took me seriously in a social
passing setting
um people aren't going to harass women
who are around me if I'm walking with
them at night which is just a benefit I
never thought about with caveat
um actually so I say that yes there are
some privileges that women have that men
don't but also there's privileges that
men have that women do I don't think
women are more privileged on our society
because I can get one pregnant and I
could just run away thank you
you can just run away technically by
that definition she could run away too
the the there's women but the courts are
Coming For That Booty
and I wouldn't call that a privilege
yeah I get a pregnant and be on the run
from the law
you don't have to pay at some point you
go that's the first time out here being
a fugitive yeah
is by not paying your child support for
you going to jail and there's enough
cases about that yeah at the end of the
day like I don't see women having more
privileges than men because we don't
have the same if there's no way to
objectively measure it well and then the
scenario that you pointed out I mean if
a woman was pregnant she wouldn't be
able to get an abortion and in some
states yes
that's a major disadvantage yeah you
know that guy is he's one of The
Producers at Jubilee who would have
thought he's a feminist
shocker you can't get an abortion but
children can go get a gender change at
12. you're very fixated without consent
that's not true
I I know the laws as well I went through
this I know in some states you can and
in Thailand you can go at 16 and get
your everything cut off guys it's less
than less than five percent it's such a
small sentence but you can't say that
about it does matter though when you
have a child you're not about between
the parent and the child can I ask you a
question though or ask the group a
question there's more world leaders who
are male and typically I think that's a
good thing I know ah damn lady can you
chill just chill
two seconds you see how she wearing her
titties out she hasn't been chilling the
moment she walks outside yo
chill two seconds so we can understand a
point that's probably not even the point
that he was trying to make Jesus coming
for me but I do want to know it doesn't
bum you out that it's less likely for a
woman to become president I don't feel
bummed out because I know that if I want
to pursue something that I want to do I
have every capability to do it in this
country I don't feel bummed out women
should not be positions of extreme
leadership like presidents Etc et cetera
because we're too emotional he shout
outs to her
she she's not just feeling the red pill
she can't even dressed as a rhythm yeah
shout outs to Heart let's see let's
let's wear pills she said she said
you're too emotional ladies you can't be
leaders listen your question about
leadership I think is a very poignant
question because a lot of people are
asking that why don't we see more female
presidents why don't we see more female
CEOs or Fortune 500 companies and again
it goes back to those gender differences
there will be women who will be
exceptions to the generalized rule of
what it means to be feminine and those
women you will see succeed in extreme
leadership but we should also discuss
what the conditions of extreme
leadership are we're talking 80-hour
work we weeks subscribing yourself to
your career and nothing else
psychologically and biologically women
tend to lean in the direction of not
making those choices for themselves
while men are highly competitive they
are highly analytical systematic they're
willing to put in that time and take
Extreme Measures to gain career status
that's a better argument than oh
emotional that's yeah that's a way
better argument she Illustrated that the
points very very well yeah I think
having her on the panel is probably the
best decision yeah yeah fantastic well
he was head yeah I mean it depends is it
true that women like report higher on
your autism sure but men report higher
on levels of aggression which I think in
a leader can sometimes be a very bad
quality too typically people that are
more in power are going to have male
attributes
and that's why women choose not to do
necessarily though inherently those jobs
and the ones that do usually quit and we
see that in uh law firms as well law
firms people are talking about yeah we
need to have more women we need to have
more more women the the amount of people
that quit those positions of powers over
the highest positions are higher when it
comes to women than when it comes to men
exactly Society is about having that
choice to make that decision
but we already have that choice
like I said in the beginning we've all
agreed that the beginning of feminism
was going in the room it was humanizing
women it was making them equal to men it
was giving us the same opportunities so
that we can go vote so that I can go get
a job so that I can drive a car like she
wants that I know that we weren't
talking about other countries but if you
want to talk about feminism go protect
the women who get beat up for driving a
car in other countries
men are falling behind in society
I just think I mean we have amazing men
here today
to see this masculine energy however I
know that men are not able to be men
anymore because of the feminist modern
feminists propaganda I coach men in my
practice and they tell me like I don't
even know if I what I can do on a date
anymore can I ask a woman out am I going
to get in trouble for this now like I
really like her I kind of want to put my
hand around her waist but maybe that's
gonna you know I'm gonna be all over
social media this kind of thing and I
think men don't have the balls anymore
to just stand up and be a man be
dangerous
you make a really interesting point I
suspect these guys are going to say men
are falling behind because they're so
restricted by what it means to be
masculine and so if they'd adopt a more
feminine however I feel like a lot of
the reasons why men can't actively
Express masculinity in a positive way is
because of the patriarchal structures
that we have
part of where I'm coming from with this
is I'm trans so I was born female now I
present this male I came out socially
and medically transitioned at 18. okay
the feminist movement is what helped me
feel empowered enough
to be who I am and be a man and no
disrespect to your process I know it's a
very strenuous thing that you go through
but I see a woman still I feel feminine
energy from you
emotional bad means
why are you going to go out like that
yeah Hey listen this is an open
discussion they share what they really
think yeah I think it's hilarious just
be like so I've been working towards
this is my whole life yeah you failed
yeah she's she's looking at me like it's
not working buddy that's all right so
when you say you're a man then it's like
I don't see that maybe it's the the
editing but to come you say say Hey
listen provide a little bit more my girl
maybe she didn't you was you was you was
ready you was ready to go in
that look like a cut though
maybe she said some flavoring [__] yeah
yeah and they were like yo that's
transformed we're Jubilee but we're
gonna cut that yeah
Choice yeah like he has this you have a
daughter do you really want to be guided
by the ambiguous Define yourself as
however you want to Define yourself and
for her mind to be molded and shaped by
men who no disrespect women who turn
themselves into men and then turn
themselves back
hey look yo I'm at it even if I don't
agree let her do her thing that's what
the conversation is but I'm just saying
I was I was just taking my surprise but
someone said you're I don't see trans
women
that's what she said she said I don't
see a trans man as a man no she said
your process is disrespectful that's
what she said that's what she said okay
so there's a lot of dissatisfaction when
the root of the problem wasn't the
gender it was everything exactly slow
down there I feel like yeah
it's like you're bundling a lot of ideas
which makes it hard to respond but is
there so much data to support you repeat
that what's the main question you want
your daughter's mind to be formed in
shape by a society that tells her it's
okay to be masculine and to be a man and
that she doesn't need a man and that
it's better off for her to be alone and
put her career first and not have
children I think it's more likely than
not that she'll probably follow a more
conventional path if my daughter grows
up and she wants to dress like a boy
like great if she for whatever reason is
experiencing gender dysphoria like we
would navigate that together but that to
me that doesn't scare me want to live in
the world I feel like that's sad because
that's a bear because my son I encourage
him I say you are to be and I really
don't care in the backlash you're
supposed to be attracted to women
no and I and I ask him what if he's not
because life for transgender individuals
and my son's African-American as well is
very freaking hard I don't know if we
can swear I'm sorry you can no I'll tell
you how to parent because they're a
child but I mean rejecting your child's
identity if they carry it over a long
period of time probably has negative
effects like my kid uh she said you have
to be attracted to women what are your
kids gay
no no you're going to be attracted to
women do you think that's gonna make
them better you don't think you're going
to put them at risk for self-deletion
because they're not attracted to women
you know what I mean like
I'm all fine for wanting to enforce your
household how you want to enforce it but
you also have to understand your child
is it what you want to mold them into
your child is still its own individual
to some degree they may be attracted to
women they may be attracted to men you
can't choose that for them you can try
to influence them you can have those
conversations you could take your time
with making any decisions that's your
parenting but you can't choose for your
child who they're gonna be attracted to
what all these things are going to be
the decisions they're going to make I'm
just saying to me that seems a very
dangerous way to parent somebody because
I know plenty of people who've had to
hide their whole Lives who they are from
their parents and that didn't turn out
well for a lot of them or the
relationship with their parents so I
would probably disagree with her on that
point even if I understand the
reluctance of wanting to embrace your
kids whole like new gender identity just
because they feel Whimsical about it
like I'm fine with parents wanting to be
very careful very prudent maybe even
against it but
like he said she is
doing an amalgamation of a lot of things
putting all different things together
and so it's hard to even stick to one
thing so the minute you go on to that
thing she flips onto something else so
just the response that she did about
would you want that for your daughter
yeah we want that to remember because I
want well that's that that and not go
into explaining why it's sad and just
like well I want that for my kid so it's
sad that you don't want that for your
kid I don't see that that's how the
world works if you don't want that
that's you I just tell them okay but to
not be their true self if that's truly
how they feel it feels like that way yes
they're not their churches that's this
way Society has influenced everybody
I can be whatever I want if I want to
say I'm Beyonce today I can now just be
Beyonce and you actually believe it
yeah
men are far behind is it because of
feminism or is there socio-economic
factors that we're not looking at well
because well no no no what do you see is
falling it's falling behind so people in
America not just men everybody is
getting poor this is nothing to do
that's a mental statement oh my babe
you struggling financially that's a
mental state like you are mentally poor
yeah yeah yeah I understand the idea
like Nabi financially literate or maybe
you're not having the mindset for
abundance but you being power poor
that's a mental state meanwhile gas and
the cost of living it rented through the
roof every [__] where like come on
bro
this is economic data you can blame the
president for that okay and the other
thing is what do you define as
masculinity it can be subjective tell us
what do you define masculine is whatever
you want to be that's not an answer you
can't just say masculinity whatever you
want it to be this is like the whole
thing I have that's so [__] with
this ideology it's like a woman's
whatever you want it to be so then why
do you want to be a woman what are you
even subscribing to if it's not a
defined thing to some degree or some
parameters even though it can be
modified to some degree it's got to be
something yeah if it's not something
dude what the [__] are you transitioning
to like I understand that someone being
fluid wants to be fluid and doesn't see
that right so it is it can be anything
yeah well they are not set on one thing
but to all the people that want to try
position they are basing themselves on
on an idea that they have if they don't
feel comfortable with what they have
and then it's considered one thing it
could be whatever you want it to be
um wrong there's some there's some
there's some things that are considered
masculine and some other things that are
considered feminine and when you come
out of there you feel some type of way
and how you're treated right if either
or
yeah and then you try to transition to
it it's because that fits in parameters
of masculinity or femininity that's what
it is it doesn't have to be this
objective thing where it's like oh
you're a mask when you're not like so it
could be different from our society to
another society and actually in some
countries like men who don't provide for
their families or are not the Sole
Provider but are we talking about other
countries even that in some countries
saying in some countries men are not
provide they're still in those countries
with the um the the parameters of those
countries that's what men do they're not
providers and it fits into what men are
doing in those countries listen if you
look at most countries you're going to
see overlapping features of what
masculine looks like for the most part
yeah there's going to be a few places
where it might be an exception right for
the vast majority of the planet ideas of
what masculinity should look like are
pretty similar it's why if I took a
person who's beekestan and then I showed
them seven individuals and I said can
you define them as men or women they
would get it right vast majority of the
time
so the idea that this is just this
amorphous thing that nobody could Define
or we can't really see that's not true
we do have a general idea of what it is
though it can be different with some
level of variants we generally know I
don't I just I hate the way that they
talk about this because it feels like a
Weasley way out of answering a question
that's really fundamental to the whole
discussion when I heard the prompt and I
heard that you know I thought about men
falling behind I thought more like
mental health like side is more common
we're gonna go here no but it's true
like men suicide like I'm not saying
mental health is yeah shut the [__] up
shut the [__] up he's agreeing with you
this dude said one sense and you just
start rattling it off oh this is let him
just [__] talk and the worst thing is
that yeah sometimes women need to be
told to shut the [__] up not because
they're women but because they're
cutting off somebody else and shut the
[__] up and the worst thing is that he's
saying that he said yes men are high
like he said something against what you
if you would just listen you would
understand why you don't think women
should be in position leadership because
you probably Define it based off your
own temperament I would not want you in
any position of leadership you need to
shut the [__] up it's an issue it is an
issue and obviously a lot of men are
having experiencing a lot of pressure
you heard like the term death of Despair
men are committing more men are dying
from alcohol-related illnesses more and
they're also dying from drug abuse and
Drug overdore smoke correct and that
that's an increasing Trend in society
no there's no denying that like young
men are abandoning colleges at a rapid
rapid it's a lot of pressure to be about
they're also far lonelier than women are
right now yeah can I finish my point
sorry sorry sorry don't let me lose my
train of thought they're abandoning
colleges women make up they enroll in
college at a 60 rate women are earning
more than men nowadays right so
um
it's about enrollment so are they having
other jobs yeah probably but I'm saying
like men are not going to these
institutions why go back to a point that
you said really quick where you talked
about like the mental health of men and
how like yeah the stigmatization of men
addressing their mental health yeah what
system are we in hey Sharkey is he
setting you up let's see if you see it
yeah he's going towards Patriots
I'm setting you up Melissa smash okay
shout out to patriarchy it's like an
all-purpose glue did you see your car
broken down
Japan got a whole patriarchy like it
just seems like this [__] fixes or is
the problem is a duct tape of feminism
go you see that on purpose all around
you yeah yeah so we are in a patriarchal
system
key
[Music]
Christ
he didn't build
something
there's a balance that's toxic Max and
complete his point I'll encourage you to
let the other person finish the point
and then of course you can take it
forward but let them talk I'm just real
quick systemic structures we were in are
patriarchy that is what has caused men
to have this massive stigma around
mental health where we don't feel
empowered to reach out men tend to not
go to therapy that leads to Suicide that
leads to all of these big things that's
not caused by feminism that was
happening well before the feminist
movement okay I'm going to say this
maybe you believe the patriarchy and all
this whatever you need to demonstrate
what it looks like just saying that
[__] word and why it stops us from
going to therapy how does a patriarchy
do that in what ways okay I'm just so
sick and tired of hearing the word
patriarchy as this amorphous power
structure that nobody can see but
everyone believes is there and you don't
explain how it tangibly affects us or
touches us invest majority of the time
that people say I don't know what the
[__] they're talking about do you yeah
how is it stopping us from getting what
is it like men saying therapy stupid is
that like how common is that like I want
to hear something don't just say a
[__] word and assume everybody has
because nobody knows what you're talking
about the patriarchy is Jesus
everybody believes in it nobody sees him
no no that's what that rules but it
rules everything is Jesus Is God Sky
daddy been doing this thing stop calling
him
praying instead of saying him and you're
like yes daddy
listen you calling yes he's a father
don't matter what name used
there's a lot of psychiatrists
psychologists and uh Economist
professors all these people coming out
saying that the actual psychology
department is feminized I know I know
but the way that everything's processed
is for women so women and men process
information differently men are like
this in their brain women are it's all
over and like what the hell does that
means
process like men need to solve the
problem correct before they can process
the emotion women
yeah that's it but so women have a
tendency not a tendency they do better
with talk therapy that doesn't always
work for a man men do better when they
are kind of working with a coach or
somebody that's going to be like this is
what you have to do and then come back
that's why mentors work that's why men
need to talk though can we let them
finish
the same problems with the military a
lot of this is that right um even though
there is Therapy Services they're
actually actively discouraged and it's
because of this masculine energy in the
military because it is still even to
this day very Ultra masculine
institution and there's these negative
energies saying like hey no you
shouldn't like go talk that's what these
[__] do but that's responsibility
there's a difference no it comes from a
place where it's like oh that's not what
men do just suck it up and push on and
that's why a lot of these guys end up
killing themselves but what what branch
are you in can I ask I was in the army
yes so you're an athlete correct and in
the military what is in the military
that makes everything work within the
military it's a structure right yes it's
a structure it's a system right who runs
the military who is at the very top of
the command or the commander-in-chief
correct in the United States but I'm
making a point here so there's one
person at the very top even if you take
the commander-in-chief away there's your
general right then there's Lieutenant
General there's Corporal and I forget
all those projects Etc yeah she skipped
like a thousand ranks but yeah fair
enough
vice president the [__] in the
kitchen the little boy at the door first
president's dog like that mother she so
you you know how you're below the
[__] dog in the chain of command
right that's why it works because this
is the dog and then there's the present
sorry
she went from General to Corporal I'm
like Corporal like one above [__]
private it's funny
it just made me laugh a lot it's just
the way she described it okay I just got
it this guy he sit back like yo what the
[__] is this [__] talking about but
he's a feminist so he can't say the b
word I said it for you bro there's a
system one person is at the top of that
system and he has supporting members
underneath him all the way down to
private and that's what patriarchy was
patriarch was designed it's a system of
one person taking a leadership position
and they make decisions for the greater
good utilitarianism you see that face
that's that what the [__] is this [__]
talking about what are you talking about
basically but I know what she's trying
to say she's trying to make the point
that patriarchy is good
it's not all bad yeah it's trying to
make the difference between
toxic masculinity which is an umbrella
term for everything that is masculine
amen and there's a difference between
patriarchy and people the thing is she
she says she said a lot of goofy [__]
but I think where she's going is that
when people see
patriarchy it's bad it's always bad when
it's actually just a thing it's not
inherently bad and people say well it's
it's a patriarchy it's like no it's not
gonna sleep bad right now what she's
describing is a hierarchy
yeah essentially and she's saying
hierarchies are good they're necessary
for the system to work yes generally
let's listen of all meaning the family
unit I that's not really what the future
is and actually it is I looked up the
definition
I literally looked it up yesterday
I really need the mail time is also to
respond because I feel like they've
spoken 20 once they're done with their
thought feel free to interrupt but let
them finish the sentence yeah like good
feminine shut the [__] up and let the it
is funny that the anti-feminists have
shown way more traditional
masculine energy
that's also part of why male feminists
lose yeah is because they just sound
Meek yeah that'll be true is that I'm
saying the perception of them is weak
and meek and you're singing this
conversation it feels very similar it
looks like they don't command respect it
looks like they're not treated well
there's a girl that said hey got girls
he was not finished with this point let
him finish it's the girl that said that
okay I want to talk I'm gonna talk I
mean I do think men are falling behind I
feel like the world is just changing in
a way where men don't have like a
natural place to fit in um or it's not
as as intuitive as it used to be and I
think men are alone I heard you
throughout the word loneliness and that
does feel true I just don't think that
feminism did that I just think like the
world is changing what you said really
resonated with me when we Define falling
behind what I think about with men is
that high suicide rate that likeliness
uh and proclivity towards violence and
aggression I think about loneliness and
not being in relationships with young
which young men are struggling with a
lot right now and where I feel finding
common ground and feminism does get
right in a sense is that we should
expand our Horizons as far as how we
view masculinity men should be able to
cry they should be able to be vulnerable
and that's something that we need to
access but also these men who are
feeling disillusioned with the world
right now they are seeking out male
figures we've seen you know the rise of
the Jordan Petersons or some of the
personalities at the daily wire or the
Andrew Tates they are seeking out
somebody who's telling them I want you
to access those masculine traits and
harness them in a way I I would say
Jordan Peterson's probably a more
healthy role model for men than say an
Andrew Tate but men are going towards
these more aggressive
masculinized traits and seeking out men
that are trying to harness that for them
she's my favorite panelist by far I
would actually say the male feminists
probably presents a lot more
common capable of having a conversation
even if I disagree then the
anti-feminist yeah and it's interesting
that they're like oh the emotional
emotional emotional being emotional yeah
it's hysterical there's just like a lot
of yelling or just incapable of making
up taking on one point and then making
that you know what I'm saying it's like
they're not very congruent with having a
conversation at least there's one yeah
there's one she's awesome I would even
say the girl in the dress beside her is
also fun women should also be drafted
into the military
okay so her argument is probably going
to be women should be drafted uh you
know since they have all these rights
they should have equal responsibility
and the men are gonna say well women are
just as competent as men so they should
be able that's why I'm suspect's gonna
happen
if you're gonna vote
will be drafted baby
listen
not hard very easy okay all right her
Pearl all these red pills they're the
same [__] yeah yeah but you couldn't see
that gun but the way you presented it
hey hey that is a 10 on 10 I believe
rights come with responsibilities and we
are all responsible individuals granted
I'm collab we live in a society where we
haven't had the draft since I think this
is
I I do think that maybe like we should
re-look at the draft and as other
options not just military service so I I
was in active duty military and I was
also in the National Guard and I fought
wildfires and like uh I've done crowd
control I've done a lot of other things
if you want the same rights you have to
have the same responsibilities and I
think that's just Universal based on
what you can do and your ability I just
disagree with this mindset so hard just
because
the idea of not having women drafted
wasn't like oh my God delicate flowers
it's like one as far as War goes for a
lot of like active Frontline personality
is not a good idea to have women on the
front lines it's not good for them or
out of the troops and they're just not
effective combatants but two it's
population if war is as devastating as
it is and so many people are gonna die
you don't need as many men as women in
order to repopulate and have kids at
post-war in order to make sure the
economy functions again it's just not
logically sensible to want to preserve
your country and then send equal amounts
of men and women to the front lines to
fight provided it's going to be as
deadly as everyone imagines it's going
to be so meanwhile that's unfair that's
unfair yes absolutely that's why you
don't get cramps only they can get
pregnant life ain't the same for the
both of us we're built differently we
have different roles and so if we're
talking about life or death the
preservation of a whole society you just
don't send men and women to war equally
not an answer you might like but that's
just effects this was a very difficult
one for me to parse through because I I
remember when I was getting my birth
certificate changed and it was like all
right time to register for Selective
Service and I was like oh God I have to
make this decision now
um to register it you don't have a
choice I know I know so I was like all
right cool drafted correct me if I'm
wrong would be going into war would be
physically going and doing no not
necessarily you can do like support
roles like military a lot of the roles
are not Frontline combat you got Cooks
uh you got intelligence operators you
got clerks you got vehicle technicians
you got Airmen who do repairs on planes
you got we will work on ships you got
like you got everything this
[__] is low-key foul foul I
thought you know you saw what he did
yeah women should get drafted because we
have a lot of positions Cooks
too you notice that I took a long time
to think of after I said Cooks what else
can these [__]
it's selective service so you register
to like be potentially needed to call
for multiple different responses right
but some of them are gone right right so
there was some so bad cases the part
that I would disagree with would be
putting women on the front lines we are
physically capable to do a lot you know
there's different boundaries for women
who go into the military who have to do
boot camp than there are for men we can
work women as hard as they can but
they're not going to work as hard as men
are I actually got accepted into the air
force which would have been like very
nice because I would had a little desk
job so I went through boot camp and it
was hell and it really messed my back up
even more than it already was it was not
boot camp it was boot camp
it seems like a lot of the same
discussions keep happening with these
prompts which is a back and forth of how
much is it nature how much does it
nurture how much are there like
intrinsic biological differences between
men and women and how much does that
dictate
um our behavior and our physiology our
biology versus how much of that is
through social learning so how much are
it's our culture in terms of let's say
like programming on a scale of one to
ten how how high is your sex drive very
high I'm a sexist I'm not asking
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
all you do is [__]
Nick funny my guy I wish the patriarchy
would shut this [__] up oh that's funny
[Music]
if you ask everyone that yeah um you'll
see on average differences between men
and women and because of that I don't
think we should dictate whether or not
someone is drafted into the military
because ultimately I think individuals
should have the freedom
to make certain choices it's a draft
because you can go in if they want and
what you're saying you don't think
people should be treated differently
because there can be metrics that fall
outside of the data of course yeah so
there is differential treatment but I
would say that it's completely
reasonable to do that because not only
are we focusing on the differential
treatment but we're focusing on outcomes
so if I'm expecting somebody to go into
combat which is the reason I didn't walk
forward you should also expect that
person on an individual basis to be able
to meet the exact same standard as every
other man that they are going to be
fighting with so the military has made a
change on that by the way they have a
new individual test that's based on what
jobs you can do if you're doing more
combat rules yes you have to be strong
and tougher and there are women Meeting
those standards that's why things are
changing and like I said I'm not for the
draft at all really I think it's a
really bad thing but if it was to happen
like it should be across all boards
everybody get treated Eagle if I could
choose
the possibility of women being drafted
or not I would choose that they're not
well I don't want anyone daughter to be
drafted I think you don't want your
daughter to be drafted awesome get this
work
it's not your daughter anymore is this
is the country's person that's it here
we go okay why would you stop there for
today yeah and if people enjoyed today's
video and they wanted us to do the
second half of this because it is 54
minutes long we can't no no you're sick
and tired of hearing the broad talk one
problem yes I want to hear the black
lady talking a lot more yeah man we
should yeah we should talk yeah so
anyways let us know what you guys look
at the comments